fabien gilot bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur rtl
france alors le débarquement de 440
migrants au cices il clôt une année de
forte migration comment ces vagues
pestel sur l'italie
c'est un problème qui est national et
international les vagues arrivent
principalement daube en sicile un petit
en calabre aussitôt même encore
seulement le s'il ya eu des arrivées en
calabre le premier point est le premier
poids il peut y avoir c'est la
répartition nationale c'est la
répartition sur le territoire puisque
les régions du sud ont déjà des
problèmes économiques assez constant il
faut donc répartir après ces migrants
sur le territoire italien de manière à
ce que toutes les régions prennent en
charge une partie pendant plusieurs
années c'était très compliqué
aujourd'hui on voit quand même que les
régions du nord parce qu'elles ont
besoin justement de la main d'oeuvre
comme le disait votre reportage prennent
de plus en plus de migrants les trois
régions qui en prennent le plus sont la
lombardie le piémont et d'emilie romagne
donc les trois régions prend les gens du
nord et donc c'est le premier cas coeur
fait comme vous l'expliqué c'est un cas
à l'international c'est la répartition
des migrants sur l'europe par exemple
qui devient le deuxième point la
deuxième négociation que doit avoir le
pays dans l'ensemble on va dire que les
chiffres sont un peu plus bas qu'avant
au niveau de la migration même si cette
année les chiffres sont plus importants
que l'année dernière on va dire
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive quand même à
gérer ce bois sans trop de difficultés
côté italien
on l'a dit un l'octroi de ces visas
de travail environ 70000 permis donc à
des travailleurs venant de pays
d'afrique du nord c'est un pas en avant
pour une certaine intégration au sein de
la société italienne
oui tout à fait c'est surtout pour moi
dire un palier à ce vide qu'il y avait
pour ces personnes qui étaient sur le
territoire italien mais sans visa
travaille donc ce qui pouvait provoquer
du travail au noir de la clandestinité
le plus simple est de trouver une
solution cette solution est proposée par
mario draghi donner des permis de
travail pour que ces personnes puissent
tout simplement s'intégrer plus vite et
pallier là aussi au problème des emplois
qu'il peut y avoir dans le nord de
l'italie et du nord de l'italie europe
en a besoin de main d'oeuvre surtout
dans certains corps de métiers où il ya
de grandes difficultés pour trouver du
personnel certains corps de
l'agriculture par exemple
certains quand la grande distribution
également ou pour la vente en ligne
gestion des stocks l'arrivée des
migrants pour certaines entreprises
italiennes est vraiment une très très
bonne nouvelle comme vous le disiez il
manque du personnel à ce niveau là je
pense que c'est un marché très
intéressant pour l'intégration de ces
personnes est également pour la relance
économique italien
on sait également que cette année donc
le chiffre des migrants est assez
impressionnant environ soixante sept
mille sont arrivés en italie alors que
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés nombre
moins 215 milles sur l'ensemble de
l'europe finalement est ce que
aujourd'hui le continent européen
l'union européenne est à la hauteur du
défi des migrations
question beaucoup plus complexe et je
pense qu'il faudrait vraiment s'étendre
plus longuement pour pour y répondre
réellement bons les chiffres sont
importants le sont toujours beaucoup
moins important qu'en 2015 il faut
toujours regarder bien sûr la liberia
irait deux fois moins de migrants qui
sont arrivés donc bien sûr que le
chiffre de cette année est important
mais le chiffre de cette année 60 7000
et deux fois moins même trois fois moins
important qu'en 2015 où il y avait plus
de 180 mille personnes qui étaient
arrivés donc le chiffre wii est
important mais relatif sur les 20
dernières années la hauteur de l'europe
est ainsi le grand débat justement que
l'italie peut avoir c'est là rendez pas
qu'il peut y avoir autour des traités
qu'il ya eu entre le lieu d'arrivée des
migrants et la répartition c'est un
grand grand grand débat qu'il faudra
très certainement ouvrir dans les
prochaines années car les vagues
migratoires continuerons bien entendu et
même si elles sont moindres aujourd'hui
il faudra quand même l'égérie froid
quand même où était une solution au
niveau européen et pas seulement les
chaînes italiennes
vous avez parlé de ces entreprises
italiennes qui manque de main d'oeuvre
et qui demandent justement à ce qu'on
délivre plus de visas à ces migrants
aujourd'hui l'italie en a besoin de ces
migrants pour pouvoir justement faire
tourner son industrie
il ya plusieurs catégories en fait à
l'intérieur de l'économie italienne qui
a besoin personnel qui peut être parfois
du personnel saisonnier notamment pour
l'agriculture au nord ou pour le
tourisme comme la région la vénétie pour
la ville de venise il ya la première
réunion pour le nombre de personnes
étrangères parce que justement il ya un
besoin de personnes qui généralement
plus parle plusieurs langues et 7 car
généralement des vivants qui arrive qui
parlent français pour les touristes
français parfois donc il y a un besoin
personnel dans cette catégorie
touristique l'agriculture également pour
certaines catégories qui sont on va dire
des tâches très pénible que parfois ne
sont pas couvertes et certains migrants
dont aucun problème à le faire le
contraire donc ça peut être une autre
catégorie est également là tels
l'industrie et la petite industrie
manufacturés parfois aussi du nord qui
est prête à former le personnel et
qu'ils étaient prêts à prendre les
migrants l'important pour eux c'est de
trouver des personnes pour travailler
dernière question très rapidement
comment réagit la population italienne
face à ces vagues de migrants
ben je pense que c'est un sentiment bien
sûr manière qui est partagée c'était il
ya l'aspect bien sûr que ces personnes
chanson général l'italie est un pays
d'accueil et qu' il est hors de question
d'abandonner des personnes je pense en
italie mais il est parfois je pense au
sentiment d'être un peu esseulé
justement par rapport à l'europe de ne
pas avoir une collaboration complète des
autres pays d'avoir toujours les bateaux
qui arrivent en italie il ya peu chez
les pays voisins donc je pense que le
sentiment est mitigé autour de cela
c'est à dire que dans tous les cas il ya
des ir d'aidé il ya le désir de sauver
ces personnes mais ce serait bien que
mon avenir pour les italiens que ce soit
un peu plus partagés sur le territoire
merci beaucoup en tout cas fabien gilot
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant à
l'université de turin